The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high-quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK, OK.
Settle down, settle down.
All right.
Today is the last lecture.
You think you're happy?
I'm happy.
So what I'm going to do, I'm
going to teach for a little
bit, wrap it up, and then I've
got some comments about the
final exam, and then some
personal observations,
reflections on the class.
So of course, the main
announcement is the upcoming
celebration of celebrations,
a week from yesterday.
The final exam will
be Tuesday, 15
December, 9:00 to noon.
I know 9:00 a.m. is kind of
early for some of you.
Use the buddy system.
Get to that room on time.
9:00 to noon in the Johnson
Athletic Center.
I'll have office hours on
Monday, 3:00 to 5:00, and
Hilary will find a room.
We'll post it, and you can
swing by, if you want.
I guess the other thing I should
say is just a reminder
about the course evals.
Please take a few minutes and
fill out the course evals, if
not for me and for your
successors, but certainly for
our TAs, so that I can write
nice things about them when
the time comes.
So last day we looked at
binary phase diagrams.
And we looked at two
different types of
binary phase diagrams.
Type one, which is the
lenticular, and type two,
which is synclinal, and in both
instances, we came upon
two-phase regimes, and when p
equals 2, that causes you to
start thinking along the lines
of phase separation.
Phase separation then
invokes a tie line.
The tie line tells you the
composition of the two phases
present, and the lever rule
tells you the relative
quantities, the relative
amounts, of
the two phases present.
What I want to do today is talk
about the last type of
phase diagram that we'll speak
about in 3091, and that's
called type three.
I came up with these
very original,
easy to remember labels.
So type three.
What characterizes type
three phase diagrams?
Well, we have partial solubility
of A and B. We're
doing all of this.
A is one of the components, and
B is the other component.
So partial solubility of A and
B, and change of state.
And the result of this set of
characteristics is freezing
point depression of
both components.
And that's different from the
situation in type one.
In type one, you see, if we
have B on the right, then
adding at A to B, if this is
pure B over here, and this is
pure A over here, adding A
to B causes the freezing
point of B to fall.
But adding B to A causes the
freezing point of A to rise.
In this type three, we're going
to have freezing point
depression of both B and A.
That's the difference between
the type one and type three.
And actually, I'm going
to approach this by a
hybridization of sorts.
So I'm going to consider
type three a hybrid.
It's a hybrid diagram of the
lens and the syncline.
I'm going to blend the lens and
the syncline, and show you
how to do that.
So let me get one of those
up here, so that
we can look at it.
So what I'm going to do
here, this is a great
diagram to look at.
It's gold nickel.
And at the top, we have a type
one, and at the bottom, we
have a type two.
And what I'm going to do, is
I'm going to mix them.
I'm going to hybridize them.
I'm going to bring this
bottom one up and have
it touch the lens.
And so we get is something
that looks like this.
We'll plot temperature
versus composition.
Left--
so here's temperature.
Composition.
On the left I have pure A and
on the right I have pure B.
And we'll start here with the
melting point of pure B. And
when I add A to B, I'm going to
get the depression that we
see in the type one diagram.
We want to start off like this,
and use everything we've
learned up until now.
So up here, we have
all liquid.
This is all liquid.
And over here, this is
a solid solution.
This is pure B, and this
is B that has a
little bit of A in it.
So we're going to use the old
metallurgical definition and
call this beta.
Beta meaning, beta is a solution
of A and B, but it's
very rich in B. It's almost pure
B. So I'm going to call
this a B-rich solid solution
of A and B.
And we know from last day, you
can't go from p equals 1,
let's get those labels up here,
you can't go from p
equals 1 to another p equals
1 without going
through a p equals 2.
So this is single phase and this
is single phase, and that
means this one here must
be two phrase.
And what are the two phases?
The two phases are the phases
that are on either side.
So this must be liquid
plus beta in here.
And that means--
phase rule-- p equals 2,
tie line, lever rule.
So that's what's going
on in there.
And then the difference is,
on this side, if this is t
melting point of A we're going
to start off with the same
concept here.
That we're going to get freezing
point depression of
A, as well.
So we'll have the liquid.
Over here we'll have
an A-rich solution.
So then I'm going to
call that alpha.
So alpha is an A-rich solid
solution of A and B. And then
that must mean that in
between here, we
have liquid plus alpha.
And these keep going.
And in addition, down at the
low end, I'm going to start
with a syncline.
I'm going to start with a
syncline, coming up like so,
and coming up like so.
See what I'm doing?
I'm taking the lens.
I'm going to meet
the syncline.
So what's here?
This is alpha, this is beta.
What's inside the syncline?
This is miscibility gap, so
this is alpha plus beta.
So let's keep the phase
labeling here.
This is p equals 2.
And look at how things have
worked out so nicely.
p equals 1, p equals 2, p equals
1, p equals 2, p equals
1, p equals 2.
So nice.
And what happens when
all this intersects?
It intersects like so.
Try to do this, stretch
it a little bit.
So these two lines connect.
They cross at this point.
They touch at this point,
the don't cross.
They just touch.
And then this arc comes up like
so, this comes down like
so, and now we have a line
across here, and this comes
down like so.
OK?
So the syncline stops at this
value, which is the minimum
temperature dictated by
the two liquidus.
We have a liquidus here and a
liquidus here, and this gets
you down to the lowest
temperature.
And let's look at the phase mix
going in this direction.
p equals 1, p equals 2, p
equals 1, p equals 2.
What's happening at
this point here?
This point, we have three
phases in equilibrium.
We have liquid, alpha,
and beta.
And this is the special
point here.
This is called the eutectic.
This is the eutectic, which is
the temperature at which we
get liquid, all liquid,
at the lowest value.
So I'm going to call this here,
I'm going to call this
point e, and e is
the eutectic.
Lowest melting point
on the diagram.
Comes from the Greek, meaning
easy melting.
And at the eutectic, eutectic
is special.
Here we have p equals 3.
It's a triple point.
The eutectic is a
triple point.
OK.
So now let's take a look
at some of the
examples of such diagrams.
All right?
This is a good one now that
winter is upon us.
This is the antifreeze
diagram.
So on the left, I have pure
water, and on the right, I
have pure ethylene glycol.
And as you can see, if you add
glycol to water, you get
freezing point depression.
If you add water to glycol,
you get freezing point
depression with a eutectic here
at roughly two-thirds.
This is in volume percent,
because that's practical unit.
When you mix glycol with water,
you do so by volume,
not by mass, or certainly
not by moles.
So if you mix two glycol with
one part water, you'll end up
with a eutectic of minus 69
degrees C, or minus 92
Fahrenheit.
So that ought to take care
of your driving needs.
All right?
Now practically speaking, we
put an equal volume mix.
So it's about a 50-50
glycol-water mix.
And that gives you liquidus
depression down to about not
quite minus 40.
It's about minus 35 Fahrenheit,
which ought to
take care of most peoples'
driving needs.
Remember, what we're trying to
do is to prevent the liquid in
the engine block
from freezing.
because if it does freeze, you
know that ice has a larger
volume than water, and that
energy is so great that you'll
crack the engine block.
So you have to prevent it from
freezing, the water from
freezing, and so you
add the glycol.
If, by chance, the temperature
dropped to minus 50, you'd
still be OK, because you'd
be in the slush
zone, two-phase regime.
You'd have some water
ice forming, but
you'd still have slush.
And by the way, why does this
not look like this?
It turns out that the amount of
solid solution behavior of
a glycol in water is
vanishingly small.
So this point is slammed
up over here.
So that's why you don't see the
right side of the lens.
And likewise, on the other
side, the amount of water
that's soluble in glycol
is vanishingly small.
So according to this scale, you
don't see the beta or the
alpha phases here.
It looks like it's pure, but
it can't be, because of the
phase rule here.
Now, you might say, well, why
don't we run pure glycol?
Because somebody might say,
I'll just run pure glycol.
Well, here's the problem with
running pure glycol.
First of all, if you get beyond
two-thirds, the melting
point rises.
But then you could say, well,
but pure glycol, the solid
glycol, has a smaller volume
than liquid glycol, so it
wouldn't freeze and crack
the engine block.
But there's another problem
here, and that is that the
viscosity of water is 1 in these
units, centipoise, and
glycol is 21.
So you'd probably burn out your
water pump by running
pure glycol, because it's so
viscous, the water pump is
going to be fatigued
by running.
And here's the point.
This is the 50-50, minus
37 degrees Celsius.
OK.
And so what I've done, is I've
superimposed the solid-liquid
diagrams with the liquid
vapor diagram.
And this is one of the times
when nature is kind.
So when you add glycol to water,
water is on the left
here, as you add glycol to
water, you get freezing point
depression, and you get boiling
point elevation.
So adding glycol to water opens
up the liquid range.
You want to stave off boiling,
because boiling will cause
lousy cooling, and the engine
will overheat, and you want to
stave off freezing, which will
cause the ice to form and
crack the engine block,
and you get both.
Then you put the pressure cap,
and then jump this up to about
265 degrees Fahrenheit.
So this is a very good example
of management of the
properties of the coolant
through chemical change.
And the binary phase diagram
eutectic type is a critical
piece here.
Again, apropos of the weather,
if you get ice on the
sidewalks, if this rain freezes,
it's terrible here.
Those of you who are in the
Northeast for the first time,
this is bad.
Not with what you see now, but
when this freezes, it's a
skating rink, and you
can't see it.
It's black ice.
You're walking along, next
thing you're on your--
you're in the horizontal
position, all right?
So we can add sodium chloride
to water, and when we do, we
cause this, a eutectic type
diagram, which can give you
freezing point depression and
prevent ice formation, and if
you get enough sodium chloride
in, you can get the
temperature down to minus
21 degrees Celsius.
And I've color coded
all of these.
This is the liquidus, this is
the solidus, and then this
line here, I can't remember if
we gave it a name last day,
this is called solvus.
This is the solvus.
This is, we know, liquidus.
This is liquidus, and this
one here is solidus.
Yeah.
OK.
So this is all color coded.
And notice that minus 21 Celsius
is not too different
from 0 degrees Fahrenheit.
Turns out, that's how the
Fahrenheit scale was born.
Daniel Fahrenheit was a
glassblower in Leyden who also
made exquisitely accurate
mercury thermometers.
And he used ammonium chloride,
not sodium chloride.
And the lowest temperature he
could get for all liquid with
ammonium chloride, he pegged
as 0 on his scale.
And it's roughly this.
It's a little bit different,
but you can see the
similarity.
Now, you need two points
to define a scale.
So he took this mercury in bulb
thermometer, put it in
the eutectic mixture of ammonium
chloride and water,
said, that's zero, calls in his
wife, tucks the mercury in
bulb thermometer under her
armpit, and says, that's 96.
And that's the birth of
the Fahrenheit scale.
And that's why we have water
freezes at 32, and it boils at
212, and all the
other nonsense.
You know, it's 98.6, but here
it's a little bit colder.
Now, why he chose 96 and 100
instead of 100 or something,
you know, you could read
in the history.
Maybe he wanted something
that was a power of two.
I don't know what the reason for
it was, but that's why we
have the Fahrenheit scale.
OK.
Now, maybe you're a little bit
hypertensive, so you don't
want to throw sodium chloride
on your walk, so you can put
potassium chloride.
But you won't get much of a
freezing point depression, And
point of fact, we usually salt
our roads with calcium
chloride, which gives
you two advantages.
Number one, very, very
low eutectic.
Number two, it's a lot cheaper
than anything else.
So it's the cheapest one to use,
and that's why we use it.
Christmas is coming, and I told
you that phase diagrams
would save the day.
We saw that the cubic zirconia
was stable in pure zirconia
only at temperatures above
2000 centigrade, which is
useless for a ring, or other
such pieces of jewelry.
But by the addition of calcium
oxide, we stabilize the cubic
form of zirconia all the way
down to room temperature.
And now we've got the high index
of refraction, clear,
colorless gemstone that
passes for diamond.
Poor man's diamond.
Cubic zirconia.
And you can see in
this regime here.
And notice that cubic
zirconia--
here's a eutectic.
Why I'm showing you this is
that the zirconia- calcia
system ultimately becomes
eutectic.
And the eutectic is at about
2300 degrees C. But over here
is the solid solution.
Notice, if it's a solid
solution, that means
it's p equals 1.
Single phase.
As it must be.
If it were two phase,
the gemstone
would be frosty, right?
You'd have all those internal
surfaces, and they'd be
reflecting.
So this is clear
and colorless.
And what's it bounded
by, this region?
Cubic zirconia plus
calcium zirconate.
So p equals 1, single-phase
field, p equals
2, dual-phase field.
And what's on the other side?
Over here it's tetragonal solid
solution, single phase.
Here's tetragonal solid
solution with cubic
zirconia, two phase.
Here's cubic zirconia,
one phase.
Here's cubic zirconia with
calcium zirconate.
Two phase.
Same concept here. p equals
1, p equals 2. p
equals 1, p equals 2.
OK.
So now you know.
When you go in jewelry
store, ask the guy,
is it single phase?
He'll say, get out of here.
Actually, you know
how they test?
The index of refraction is
so high with zirconia.
It's a little bit less
than diamond.
Diamond's up around three.
Cubic zirconia is over two.
One of the ways they test is,
diamond has a very high band
gap, about 5.5 electron volts.
But it's got the remarkable
property, even though it's an
electronic insulator, it's a
very good thermal conductor.
Most materials that are poor
conductors of electricity are
poor conductors of heat.
But diamond, for reasons I can't
explain with just the
utility of a 3091 education, has
a good phonon transmission
properties.
And the way they tell cubic
zirconia from diamond, is they
actually put a couple of tips
on either side of the stone,
and they heat one tip, and
measure the time lag for the
thermal wave to get
to the other tip.
And if it's cubic zirconia, it
takes a long time, because
cubic zirconia is
an insulator.
If it's diamond, it's almost
like metallic conduction.
And that's how they
can tell a fake
diamond from a real diamond.
Here's, you know, I've
been drinking from
these cans all semester.
And this is the alloy system,
aluminum magnesium.
So we put about 1% magnesium
into the aluminum.
So here's pure aluminum
over here.
It goes down to eutectic.
This is pure magnesium
over here.
They both melt at roughly
the same temperature.
And by putting about 1%
magnesium in here, it changes
the metallurgical properties
favorably.
Notice we don't want to put 4%
or 5% magnesium in here.
Otherwise, as we get down to
room temperature, we'll enter
a two-phase regime,
and that means we
won't be able to process.
Because this can is made from
a single sheet of aluminum.
The body of the can.
There's two pieces, the
top and the body.
There's no third bottom here.
Start with a flat sheet of
aluminum and it's punched
deep, drawn down, up,
down, and it gives
you the whole shape.
And you have to have, you
know, this is FCC.
You have to have the glide.
Dislocations are gliding, the
slip systems are operative,
and the magnesium gives you just
a little bit of strength.
But if you get into the
two-phase regime, the punch,
instead of making deep
drawing metal, will
end up punching holes.
So what's the difference
between drawing
and punching holes?
It's all in the metallurgy.
So you can see, this
is where we are.
OK.
Ah!
Microelectronic devices.
How do we hold all those
wires together?
With solder.
And this is the phase
diagram for solder.
It's made of lead and tin.
And we use eutectic.
The eutectic here is about 62
weight percent tin at 183
degrees Celsius.
I took a class in high school
called Industrial Arts.
It was shop.
We had it drilled into us, the
eutectic point of soft solder
is 374 degrees Fahrenheit.
I will know that
on my deathbed.
Plus the wavelength of copper
K-alpha radiation.
1.5418 angstroms.
Yeah.
So what's the magic here?
The magic here is, the solder
must be low-melting enough
that when you're-- remember,
you've got your
microelectronic device.
You've already got your chip,
and you're putting wires.
You want to put enough heat in
to solder the wires, but you
don't want to have to raise the
temperature so much that
you can damage the rest
of the device.
So you say, well, why don't
you get something
that's lower melting?
Well, if it's lower melting,
you know from running your
laptops and charging your cell
phones, they get warm.
So it's a Goldilocks problem.
If the melting point of the
solder is too low, you might
encounter that temperature
in service, and
pop all of the joints.
If the melting point of the
solder is too high, then you
have to use so much energy to
make the joints that you
damage some of the
microelectronic componentry.
So this has to be in the right
temperature range.
The problem with this excellent,
excellent solder is
that it contains lead.
No one's going to get lead
poisoning from using a device.
But the disposal of the device
ends up introducing the lead
into the landfill, and then
if it soaks in an aqueous
solution, you could get
leeching, et cetera.
So there's a lot of research
right now on trying to find
other solders that operate.
And there are other solders,
but they're very expensive.
So that, how do you find
something that's functional
the way this is, nontoxic,
and cheap?
They can give you any two of
those, but to get all three of
them to line up?
Requires research.
You see the alpha phase, beta
phase, everything there.
All right.
And here's the lead
tin system.
And let's just take this one
that happens to be 40%, and
let's see what happens.
We'll go through in time.
So we start here, all
liquid regime.
And so this bubble shows
what you might see on
a microscope slide.
So it's all white here, meaning
that it's homogeneous
single phase.
And then you drop into the
two-phase regime, just below
the liquidus, and you start
seeing these blobs.
Those little blobs are
the primary alpha.
That's the solid solution,
right?
Because we're in the two-phase
regime, so we've
got a tie line here.
We get down to a lower
temperature, there's more of
this stuff.
There's more of this stuff
forming , because
it's forming in time.
It takes you time to
traverse this.
This isn't parking
and waiting.
This is just cooling
something.
Imagine you're soldering, so you
took the temperature up to
here, now you're going
to let it cool.
Once you cross the eutectic
temperature, now
it's alpha plus beta.
So now you get this lamellar
structure.
Stripes of alpha,
stripes of beta.
But the previous blobs that
formed the primary alpha, they
don't disappear.
The only way they
can disappear is
by solid state diffusion.
That's going to take
a long time.
So I can look at the
microstructure
here, and I can predict--
not predict--
I can go back and calculate
what the cooling
rate must have been.
If I cool very slowly,
I will have nearly
the equilibrium structure.
And so that's why, when I told
you about, say, analyzing the
records from the World Trade
Center, I can look at the
metal, and look at the phase
distribution, and tell you
what the thermal history was.
And so for example, there was
some cock-eyed theory saying
that the steel was burning.
Somebody said that the steel
melted, and so on.
You can look and you say,
that did not happen.
Temperatures went fairly high,
crossed into some different
solid phases, went from BCC
to FCC and then back.
But didn't melt.
Because if it melted,
we would have seen
this kind of structure.
So this is--
every time a plane crashes,
this is the metallurgical
investigation that
is taking place.
The history is written in
the microstructure.
So this is a micrograph
that's actually
taken from some solder.
This is 50 weight percent.
The slide was 40, but this
happened to be 50.
It's the one I could
find easily.
So 50 tin, 50 lead, and these
dark zones are the primary
lead-rich alpha.
And it's all metal.
So how do I get the dark
and the light?
First we polish, because it's
an optical microscope, which
has a really crummy
depth of field.
So you've got to make it flat,
and you polish it, and now
you've got a mirror, and
you look, and all
you see is your eyeball.
So what you do then, is you
etch it with some acid.
And the lead will etch at a
different rate from the tin.
And the contrast, then,
is what you see here.
So this is all the blobs
of primary alpha.
Then you go below the eutectic,
and, you know, this
cute little schematic
of stripes--
this is the textbook version
of it, but this is the real
version of it.
And you see, it's a distorted
lamellar structure.
Alternating stripes.
Because you're trying to
make alpha and beta.
And so you're making alpha and
beta, and the system's trying
to make both of it.
So it makes it in striped
form called lamellar
microstructure.
So I can look at that
and I can say, wow.
That must have been cooled at
a fairly rapid rate, because
you've got a large amounts
of primary alpha.
If it were cooled at a very slow
rate, the thing should be
all lamellar structure, right?
If you're down here, there
should be no alpha.
This is not the equilibrium
phase.
So this alpha is
trapped there.
It's a victim of its history.
So there it is.
That's cute.
That's a nice, it's a
beautiful graphic.
See?
There it is.
All right.
So I'm going to show you some
phase diagrams from hell.
This is, you're going
to be on airplanes.
The airplane alloy is
aluminum copper.
It's about 4% copper
and aluminum.
Now remember, I just told you
about 1% magnesium and
aluminum to give you
single phase.
In the case of the airplane,
we want to
make the wings strong.
So what we do, is we come down
into here, which is a
two-phase regime.
And if we're clever about it,
we can control the particle
size of that second phase.
And by controlling the particle
size, we can cause
grain boundaries, which can
arrest the dislocations and
make sure the wings
don't fall off.
This is aluminum manganese.
This is the one that Danny
Schechtman worked with to get
the quasicrystals.
Look at all the phases.
He's running out of Greek
letters by the time you get
across this diagram.
Look at it.
But one thing holds.
The two-phase regimes are
always bounded by
single-phase regimes.
Look.
Here's liquid, here's a two
phases, there's a single
phase, two phase, single
phase, two phase.
Beautiful.
All makes sense.
Now, what happens if you try
to take a metal and mix it
with a nonmetal?
They don't want to mix.
Look at the big miscibility
gap here.
Molten iron doesn't want to
mix with molten sulfur.
This is a liquid-liquid
miscibility gap.
Over here, you can add some
sulfur to iron, you get a
eutectic, get a line compound.
And then over here, no dice.
Does not want to mix.
And look at all the
solid phases.
Why do we have all these
solid phases?
Different crystal structures.
OK.
So now what we're going to do,
is I'm going to talk about
application of phase diagrams
to the making of champagne.
Because champagne relies
on phase diagrams.
And then I'm going to make
some general comments.
But I'm going to actually
show you some champagne.
So before I get into my
commentary, I'm going to get
some champagne chilling.
So first I have to show you
how to chill champagne.
First I will show you how
not to chill champagne.
This is how not to
chill champagne.
And it's not because, OK,
we can put it in there.
Why?
Because, as I showed you last
day, with respect to the
cooling of the engine coolant by
the radiator, if you have--
if this a bottle here,
here's the contents,
the precious contents.
And I have this with
blocks of ice.
The contact between the ice and
the bottle is sporadic,
and I've got air in between, so
the quality of the cooling
is very poor.
So instead, what I do is I rely
on the phase diagram.
So what do I do?
What do I know about
the phase diagram?
if I pour water in here, I will
thermostat the entire
system, liquid plus solid,
at 0 degrees.
Because the ice is probably,
I don't know,
minus 3, minus 4 Celsius?
But the air is 20, and
it gets in there, and
it's very few atoms.
It's crummy heat transfer.
Instead, if I flood this with
water, the whole thing is
thermostatted at 0 degrees C.
So now I've got a good delta t,
because I started here at
about 22 degrees C. I've
got a delta t, and it's
a fixed law, right?
It's going to be what?
It's going to be the flux.
The heat flux is going
to be minus thermal
conductivity, dt by dx.
It's Fickian type motion
of the thing.
So let's do it.
This is how you properly
chill--
I'm told it also works for
sodas and fruit juices.
This technique, I mean.
But I do know that it works
with champagne.
Now that's working
beautifully.
I can just feel the heat
being extracted.
OK.
So now let's talk
about champagne.
All right.
So we're going to talk about
champagne and a great
inventor, and the inventor
is the Widow Clicquot.
This is the Veuve Clicquot
champagne.
And veuve is the French
for widow.
So Veuve Clicquot,
her real name was
Nicole-Barbe Ponsardin.
And in 1798, she married
Francois Clicquot.
This is a big French
winemaking family.
And he died and left her a
widow at the age of 27.
She was very unusual for a
French woman in the 18th
century, because they were
not involved in society.
They were certainly not
involved in business.
This woman was different.
She decided to get under the
hood, and she took control of
the winery.
And I've written here, bold,
imaginative management.
There's a fantastic
book about her.
It's actually a very good book
portraying late 18th century,
early 19th century France.
And these are among her
accomplishments.
Marketed champagne to all the
great courts of Europe.
Champagne was a regional
beverage, drunk only in the
Champagne region.
And she created the myth,
propagated the myth of champagne.
You use it for festive
occasions, bought land in the
best vineyards, quality
control.
It's about the chemistry.
Fought fiercely against
counterfeiting.
As she started getting champagne
more recognition,
people started making sparkling
wine and labeling it
as champagne.
She used the court system
to take them down.
Established strict quality
control procedures.
That's all about defending
the brand, and
what's the quality control?
It's the chemistry.
Produced the first
rose champagne.
The Pinot Noir grape
has a black skin.
Depress, and then take the
juice, and away you go.
What she did, is she let the
skin sit with the juice for
long enough to give a
just a rose tinge.
And then oversaw the invention
of new technology.
Remouillage.
And that's where the phase
diagrams come into play.
Phase diagrams give us champagne
we enjoy today.
So what's the problem?
Champagne is cloudy.
Why is it cloudy?
Well, here's the chemistry.
Here's how you make, this is
how you make all wine.
It's one-stop shopping.
You take the grape.
The grape has sugar in
the grape juice.
And yeast that attacks the
sugar is in the skin.
So the yeast attacks the sugar
to make alcohol and CO2.
So ethyl alcohol and CO2,
plus some insolubles.
There are some insoluble
products of that reaction.
And there's two types
of insolubles.
Those that will settle, they're
called sedimentary,
and those that won't settle.
They're called suspended.
And how do you get rid of
the sedimentary stuff?
By mechanical separation.
You let the juice sit, this
reaction is taking place, and
the sedimentary stuff is turning
into gunk, and it sits
at the bottom.
And then periodically
you siphon.
You siphon the juice off, and
you leave all the crud at the
bottom of the barrel, and then
you go for a few more months,
and then you siphon again.
Well, that works for the
sedimentary stuff, but it
won't work for champagne,
because as you're siphoning,
you're letting out
all the gas.
You see, you're trapping
this gas.
The champagne has CO2 that's
naturally occurring.
It's not carbonated.
It's carbonated naturally.
Not carbonated, man-made
carbonation.
It's natural carbonation.
So how do you separate the juice
from the crud without
losing the gas?
That's the problem.
And by the way, the other stuff
that's suspended, they
use tricks.
You know, here's the
free body diagram.
Remember, I showed you
this for milk.
So what they do, is they add
things like eggshell, and the
eggshell acts as a coagulant,
so the tiny particles that
will float agglomerate to become
big enough that then
they'll settle.
Tiny particles of a given
density will float, large
particles of the same
density will sink.
So you need to coagulate,
and do that without
spoiling the taste.
Fantastic chemistry.
So she comes along
with the answer.
By the way, the early
champagne glasses
were all cut crystal.
Why were they cut crystal?
Because the champagne
was cloudy.
It tasted fantastic, but who
wanted-- it looked like swill!
So how to make it clear?
So what they did, is they made
champagne bottles with the
deep ruts, and they still
do to this day.
They have a deep rut here,
because the idea was, if you
opened it carefully, you
wouldn't disturb
so much of the crud.
But it gets churned
up by the gas.
So what she reasoned was, let's
turn him upside down,
and let's have the crud settle
on the underside of the cork.
And furthermore, 45 degrees
is the optimal angle.
You know this from your
Newtonian mechanics.
And then you turn them, so
you spiral the bottle.
Turn them, and have all the crud
collect on the underside
of the cork.
I know what you're thinking.
How are you going to
get the cork out?
Now you take the cork out,
you're going to lose
not just the gas.
You're going to lose
the liquid, too.
Ah, that's where the phase
diagrams come in.
So here's a phase diagram
of ethanol water.
And it's eutectic.
Look at, way down here.
In fact, ethanol makes a
really good antifreeze.
Look!
A little bit of-- go
way down here.
Now, most wines are somewhere
between 10% and 15% alcohol,
that gives you very modest
freezing point depression.
Maybe about minus 5 Celsius.
Which is why if you forget, you
put a wine bottle in the
freezer and you forget about
it, and you've got your
freezer really cranked to,
say, minus 5 Fahrenheit,
you'll freeze the wine, and
it'll expand, because it's 90%
water, and push the cork
out, make a mess.
But remember, you only get
down to about minus 5.
Remember, I showed
you this one?
It gets down to minus 21.
So what she reasoned was,
what if you took the
bottle upside down?
You've got all the crud on the
underside of the cork.
What if you took the bottle and
put it into not water, but
what if I put sodium
chloride in here?
I still have my ice cubes,
only the temperature
is now minus 21.
And that's below the freezing
point of the alcohol, and now
I've frozen an ice
plug in the neck.
So now there's an ice plug
between the crud and the cork.
So now I can turn the bottle
like this, just melt ever so
slightly, and the pressure in
the bottle will blow the ice
plug, take with it the crud out,
and then I quickly put
the cork on top.
And that's how every bottle
of champagne is made.
And it all comes from these
phase diagrams.
See?
So you put it in brine.
Minus 21.
But this thing is
frozen already.
That red is frozen.
And now I've turned it right
side up, out it goes, takes
the crud with it, put
the cork back on.
So it's a combination
of this phase
diagram, this phase diagram.
Both eutectic phase diagrams
would give us clear champagne.
Positively brilliant.
So there it is.
The invention and--
oh, by the way.
They call this--
the English word remouillage
is riddling.
So they have people that
actually go, and they, these
wooden racks with the slots in
them at 45 degree angles, and
all these bottles are pointed
downward, 45 degree angle.
Guys come in every day, quarter
turn, quarter turn,
quarter turn.
French are very traditional.
Few champagne wineries have
motorized, so they have this
thing called giropalette.
Gyrating pallet.
The California champagne
wineries call it VLM.
Very Large Machine.
I kid you not.
I didn't make that up.
In California, the giropalette
is called VLM, which is Very
Large Machine, dude.
I guess.
That's what they say.
California.
All right.
So let's have a few words now
about the final exam.
So you know, it's going
to be Tuesday, 9:00 to
noon, Johnson Athletic.
Three hours.
You have three full hours, not
three times 50 minutes.
Three full hours.
But I'm not going to give you
three times the work.
It's sort of a hybrid between
intensive coverage since T3,
so sort of like a T4 and
a redemptory part.
It'll go back, extensive
coverage of everything.
One aid sheet.
I'm saying it three times.
Do not come in there with
a bunch of aid sheets.
Well, I didn't know!
I thought we could have--
no!
One aid sheet.
That's all you need.
And the TAs are smart.
You know, every year somebody
tries to bring the origami and
all that stuff.
And they get caught, and
then-- you know.
Bring your periodic table,
table of contents,
calculator, a pen.
No headphones, no audio.
Please.
Because people are writing,
they're trying to concentrate.
I don't want to get into a
dispute over whether your
music is too loud for
your neighbor.
So let's just, out of
courtesy, no audio.
You can go three hours
without your music.
All right?
What else.
This is going to be comparable
difficulty
to the monthly tests.
Of course, read the
entire exam.
You've got plenty of time.
Most people are leaving
11:15, 11:30.
It's not a race against
the clock.
And make sure you show your
work, justify your
conclusions, solve
algebraically.
Stay confident.
Do your own work, academic
honesty, all that applies.
Now, your overall grade is
going to be based on many
factors, including the trend.
So we're going to look
at how you performed
throughout the semester.
You started off really strong,
and you crash and burn on the
final, or you've done the math
and you say, I only need a 37
on the final, and you go in
there, shooting for a 37, and
you miss and you get a 35, and
your total average is 49.5?
You go down.
Because you've got a 49.5 and
you wrote a 35 on the final.
I'm just telling you.
Claim, you can have your
exam papers back.
But don't come and see
us before Christmas.
You can have them back
starting IAP.
So starting January 4, you
can have your exams
back, if you want them.
And there's no time limit for
appeal, so you don't have to
be bursting into your TA's
office on January 4 if you see
that we've misgraded
something.
You can come and see us.
There will be some security
measures in place.
It has not escaped my notice
that some people have
attempted to erase answers that
were written in pencil,
and then bring in this
newly brilliantly
solved problem for regrading.
And that's, of course,
qualifies as academic
dishonesty, and I'll take you to
the committee on discipline
if you try it.
But just to inspire honesty
on a random basis, we'll
photocopy about 5%
of the exams.
So if you want to try this, the
question you've got to ask
yourself is do you feel lucky?
Do you?
All right.
So now it's time for some
personal observations.
So I wrote them down.
OK.
So first thing is, you've
come a long way.
Syllabus is full.
You think about where we were
on day 1, you know, this is
equations, stoichiometry,
all that baby stuff.
And you know, look.
So be proud of what
you've learned.
Number two.
I wish you much success
on the final.
Remember, no grade that I assign
to you, or any of my
colleagues assigns to you has
any relevance to your value as
a human being.
It's just a grade
in a subject.
That's all it is.
What's the worst thing
that can happen?
Suppose you get all Fs, and
you're required to withdraw
from the Institute.
So what?
You know?
You're all smart people.
I know you're smart.
I used to chair the Admissions
Committee.
I know how smart you are.
If you're getting all F's, this
is not the right place,
it's not the right time
for you to be here.
Look, I have no degrees
from this place.
I feel great.
I've been teaching here at MIT
for 32 years, and I've never
enjoyed teaching as much as
I have this semester.
This has been really a blast
to teach, really.
I can't believe I said that
with a straight face.
So of course it's not true.
I want to think my staff.
My TAs, sitting here.
The tutors who helped out.
Professor Demkowicz, who subbed
for me that time, when
I had the visit of
President Obama.
Administrators, the
audiovisual techs.
Dave Broderick, who's done a
great job of making sure that
we have sound and light.
And the academic media
production services people,
who have recorded the lectures
so that on the rare occasion
that you didn't make it
the class, you're
able to catch up.
And the last thing is that,
I've got here, there's one
more chemistry lesson.
You know, we've learned about
the four different types of
primary bonding.
Covalent, ionic, metallic,
and in some
instances, van der Waals.
But there's a fifth
type of bond.
The fifth type of bond that I
haven't talked about yet.
And it's the type of bond that's
been forming in this
room over the last 14 weeks.
Yeah, I know.
It's kind of sappy.
I didn't come up with this.
It came from a student.
So the fifth type of bond is--
it's not this one.
[MUSIC PLAYBACK]
No, it's not this one.
It's a bond that's formed
between people, and this bond
has a very special property.
It can never be broken.
I know!
It came from a student.
It's very sappy.
I'll tell you the story.
I'll tell you the story
how it happened.
I used to teach 321,
which is a core
graduate class in kinetics.
And I'd been teaching
it for, I don't
know, five, seven years.
And I was at a conference, and
there's these two people
standing there talking.
And I know both them.
One was from industry, and
one of them was an alum.
So I go up, and the fellow in
industry, says, hi, how are
you doing, do you
know so and so?
And I said, yeah.
He was at MIT.
I was his kinetics professor
And the student, the alum,
he says, excuse
me, Professor Sadoway.
It's true that I was at MIT, but
please do not say that you
were my kinetics professor.
You will always be my
kinetics professor.
I went, oh, man.
This is really something.
So now the tables are turned.
And, and, you know, I know
you're going to go go on and
do something remarkable in your
life, and I hope it's
remarkably wonderful and
not remarkably stupid.
But you know, at some point,
somebody may say to you, where
did you learn your chemistry?
And you'll have to say,
Sadoway at MIT.
So whether you like it or not,
I will always be your
chemistry professor.
So now, let's see.
I think it's time to open
up the champagne.
So first thing, we
have to teach
you how to open champagne.
So there's the foil here.
So we'll take the foil off.
Take the foil off,
very carefully.
And then there's the wire basket
that keeps the cork on.
How many turns on
the wire basket?
Everyone in 3091 knows.
Six turns.
One, two, three, four,
five, six.
Six turns.
And so now, I don't want to
point that at anybody, because
the only thing between me
and six atmospheres of
pressure is that cork.
And Dave, if we can cut to
the document camera.
The cover, the metal cover on
this, has the image of the
Widow Clicquot.
This is Veuve Clicquot, and
this is the image of the
Veuve, and she's on
every bottle.
She was the one that gave us
clarified champagne, so you
thank her very much.
All right.
So now what we're going
to do, is we're going
to open this thing.
To open it, we point
it 45 degrees and
turn it ever so slightly.
Never point it at people.
No, really, point it away.
You'll put an eye out
with this thing.
You turn it very slightly.
Actually, my hands are wet now,
so I'm going to use a
towel here.
Oh yeah.
Go like this.
You like the suspense, huh?
See that?
No pfff!
That's for football
locker rooms.
It's very declasse.
OK.
Now we have to have a glass.
So since we have clarified
champagne, we're not going to
use cut crystal.
We're going to use Baccarat,
French crystal that's not cut.
Because we've got nothing
to hide, right?
So now we're going
to pour this.
And the rut now has
some value.
The rut has value, because
now what you can do is to
pour it like so.
I've been waiting fourteen
weeks for this.
All right.
So the surface tension, you
see the carbon dioxide
outgassing, because it's
supersaturated.
Six atmospheres, not
one atmosphere.
The bubbles are nucleating on
the defects in the glass.
It's all about chemistry.
So there we go.
OK.
So I'm going to propose a toast
to the class, to the
3091 class of Fall 2009, to wish
you much success in your
academic pursues, and
much happiness in
your personal lives.
And with that, I'm
going to find out
what's going on inside.
Look at those bubbles!
You know, the legend is, the
blind monk, Dom Perignon, when
he first drank champagne, said,
I feel as though I'm
drinking stars.
He's right.
Drinking stars.
OK.
This is to you.